welcome back to New rockstars and
She-Hulk episode 6 finally introduced
the Intelligentsia to the MCU as the
likely NC going after Jennifer's blood
but the question remains why like why
are these random creepy men trying to
get under Jennifer's skin huh well what
if I told you that What's Happening Here
is a setup for Captain America the
fourth what if I told you that this
could be the first steps to introducing
yet another Captain America type super
soldier to the MCU this is Rogue Fury
the show where we pitch the wildest
theories for the nerdy titles that we
love my name is Mt and growing wrong
with me today is the moderator of the
Titania did nothing wrong.com website
it's Jessica Clemons what's going on
Jess hello there
Obi-Wan Kenobi Jess hello there I'm
getting my properties mixed up I'm so
tired but we'll get there and of course
we have The Keeper of the dark hold
herself it's your girl Whitney van
laningham what's going on Whitney I keep
the darkness
oh baby underneath my pillow at night
that's why I didn't sleep because the
dark hole has taken over it's all those
Souls of the damn being so damn loud on
that book come on guys Ash come on get a
little shut eye and finally we of course
have the vice president of the
Intelligentsia In the Flesh here with us
it is Mr Matt Acevedo what's going on
Matt hello hello yes I thought we were
just selling coffee beans turns out we
are an evil organization so let's go
don't don't slander Matt by lumping him
in with those in cells come on
they'll all wait 30 minutes for a cup of
coffee in Silver Lake oh yeah for all of
our Rogue Theory listeners who don't
live in the Los Angeles area
Intelligentsia is an extremely
overpriced hipster-ass coffee place in
Silver Lake that way too many men with
beards and no deodorant wait really so
that's that's yes that's what you're yes
intelligencia is a coffee place here wow
but it's only forever
you can't go if you're not like
extremely hip if you walk in wearing
anything less than something that looks
like uh Mumford and Sons would wear in
2010 you get kicked if you want to feel
like you're judged for getting a cup of
coffee go there
I like a little judgment with my cup of
Joe but this leads us to our first topic
of today I believe that the
intelligentia wants to create the mutant
growth hormone that we see in the Marvel
Comics if you don't know what this is
basically it's like a drug that Marvel
characters take if they want temporary
superpowers and it doesn't last forever
and it sort of like simulates the power
of a mutant but in the comics um a
mysterious group creates a mutant growth
hormone uh from the blood of like
various super powered people it doesn't
have to be a mutant per se so I believe
that the Intelligentsia wants to use
Jennifer's blood to usher in the mutant
growth hormone for the MCU because we
know that on Patriot is coming to the
MCU we saw him in uh Falcon in the
Winter Soldier he is Isaiah Bradley's
grandson and we know in the comics that
he takes this vegan growth hormone to
sort of pretend like he inherited the
powers from his grandfather but he's
actually just taking this struck and we
know that you know like uh Wilson Fisk
he's unnecessarily strong can rip off a
clock car door for some reason and uh we
like I just feel like and it also uh
Jessica Jones
um her her powers will probably be
linked to the um growth hormone as well
so I think that this is the first steps
of getting Jen's blood is uh the
intelligentious way of sort of flooding
the world with this mutant growth
hormone likely
um to help Hydra create more chaos in
the world because the more people that
have powers the more chaos that you have
and like the more people will seek
someone to sort of Control the Chaos but
all that aside what do you guys think of
this I think it's fun yeah it's fun I
think everyone gets superpowers let's go
let's go
you get powers you get levitation you
get lasers out of your eyes
yeah I definitely think that some
someone's gonna get a hold of this this
is gonna leak out and someone's gonna
use it you know I'm obviously until he's
gonna use it I keep saying is it until
intensity now like it's officially
gensia but that's soft G so I don't
actually until intelligencia I actually
don't know much about from the comics so
this is New Territory for me but I think
it's going to lead to some sort of
bigger kind of thing you know I
definitely think it's gonna you know be
involved with some sort of mutant
mutation in the future it's going to
help get you know obviously get more
people's superpowers I think that we're
gonna have uh maybe like aim will come
back I don't think we'll I think we're
kind of done with Hydra for now
um I just don't see Hydra coming back
anytime soon uh but I kind of think like
aim I get a hold of it and use that to
like bolster up their their like you
know their guys their grunts uh and
we'll get some sort of like superhuman
war and then like you know in Manhattan
and all these all the different teams
that are there because like the
Defenders the Young Avengers The
Avengers the mutants were kind of
building up to like this kind of all out
like superhero war in Manhattan I think
man bro like I I have been wanting a
Civil War Two for the longest time
especially now considering that She-Hulk
is introducing so many super powered
people like that we've ever seen in the
MCU before so like we gotta get a civil
war to go come on come on can we please
get Civil War Two to just be Titania and
She-Hulk fighting at a wedding
oh my gosh please ten more hours yeah
let's get back going let's get the whole
match going oh that would be listen I
recent I recently got engaged and if
both of those [ __ ] don't show up and
start a fight at my wedding I'm
canceling my life
a little tangent that wedding episode
was fantastic uh I thought it was super
fun Patty Harrelson is a queen oh my God
I am obsessed with him and she was so
goddamn good yeah but I think we are
living in the Civil War too though I
think that's like you know we had Civil
War Two in the comics we're seeing a
little bit of it with like Captain
Marvel where like young you know uh
Heroes need to be kind of like held
accountable or like not you know I think
we're kind of building towards that
Civil War Two was about the young hero
registration act if I I think that's
correct uh and how like you know they
need to register and stuff like that
Tony Stark was uh was the one leading
that thinking that that was wrong and it
was actually Carol Danvers who's the one
who's like Pro like they should register
I think I got that right I might have
flipped those but I'm pretty sure that's
what it was that was the first one the
second one was about um like they have
this inhuman that can see the future and
so like Minority Report oh that's right
it was uh sorry I got that mixed up
you're right I totally forgot and he was
and it was like he was able to see uh it
was I think it was Miles killing like
cap and then it was like we had to
prevent this before it happens and
that's what it was sorry no it's okay
yeah got that mixed up I think our next
Civil War Two Is Secret Wars
um I think that's the next time we're
gonna see everyone gets split into two
sides
um and it'll be better because it's
Superheroes versus Villains
um but uh to your theory Mt I like it
like what you said my one thing is How
likely do you think they're gonna be
trying to take the mutant Gene from a
Hulk and and that would become the
mutant Gene is are you trying to say
that would be the start of the mutant
Gene would be the Hulk's blood oh no I'm
saying like specifically the mutant
hormone drug because like it's called
the mutant hormone drug in the comics
but like historically in the comics they
don't have to necessarily get that um
that data for the for the drug from a
mutant you can get it from any type of
super powered person so um I'm thinking
that they're going to do that in the MCU
and be like all right person with weird
enhanced DNA let's just use that to
create um the mutant grow mouth it
doesn't like doesn't really have to be
from a mutant per se but they're just
going to Market it like that because
you're mutating blood that's interesting
that they wouldn't just take from
themselves or they wouldn't take from
someone that's less you know breakable
or unbreakable as She-Hulk but I like
the idea that them starting research if
the Intelligentsia is starting like they
are in the comics and they're just
trying to become like a massive
knowledge they're probably just trying
to get everyone's blood so they can like
test it all and then be like where the
one blood we don't have is the whole
blood so maybe that's when they're
trying to like break off and get
she-hulk's blood to test
um because she's easier to get and also
no one knows where Hulk is because he's
off world so I like the idea of it I'm
interested in it
okay it sounds like a cow
I want to see like a you know I I think
someone like like what like like a
mutant could take it and they amplify
their power to like like a cyclops okay
and his like blast is just massive you
know what I mean like I want to see you
know we're building to a hero is like I
have no choice and like they take it
themselves
just like the soldier serum Cyclops
becomes too wide Normal Man
stupid I would be
what Matt said I agree with I could see
that happening in retrospect that
instead of getting their blood to
further like study they're more so
getting it to get the gamma radiation so
that they can defeat a hole I like the
idea of them taking her blood to test it
to either make an army or to make you
need to get the disease in order to beat
the disease so what if they are just
just grabbing it so they can make a
gamma radiation that could actually take
her out I like the idea of them doing it
in both ways that's cool yeah yeah I
mean I guess the threats are like
they're they're big threats now there's
no secrets there's literally a Celestial
sticking out of like what's in the ocean
you know like like and you know people
gotta be prepared what is that guy up to
I need to go what is
a 24 7 like Tia much day five like where
they have like a drone in the sky that
just like watches them at all times tune
into the live footage whenever you want
Oh My
God's head everyone laughs like a Marvel
Studios website they just have a live
feed
yeah
I would like a Disney plus short about
that
hell yeah he looks like he's like
perpetually reciting Shakespeare because
like to be or not to be that is the
question
so dude I really like this a lot because
uh oh wait first of all number one thing
it's intelligencia now okay well it's
not intelligencia or Intelligentsia it
is in selling 100 because those people
were just like ew she's green and a girl
and it's like a pick a better point my
guys like it's a better Hill to die on
she's hottest it's true and and they
were on Reddit which makes it even even
worse
just seriously just like put put down
the laptop go outside a little bit make
some friends in cells please stop
seriously uh stop trying to still steal
someone else's blood it's not cool uh
and then second of all uh I really liked
this Theory because the way that you
were describing
um like Patriot taking seeing the like
whatever the hormones or the serum or
whatever they end up calling it uh
taking it so that he can like fake
inheriting the powers because that it
kind of reminded me of the first Hulk
movie where Emile Blonsky takes the
serum and then he tries to fight The
Hulk and realizes oh [ __ ] I can't I'm
not actually like powerful enough and
then that's like what drives him to go
harder go harder turn into Abomination
and so I think that it would be really
interesting to see Patriot be like okay
I'm supposed to follow in my
grandfather's footsteps and then he gets
his ass kicked and then he's like okay I
can't get my ass kicked again that was
horrible I'm gonna go get this like
human growth hormone so that I can kick
ass just as hard as everyone expects me
to that would be so cool I'm fully on
board for that I love it like I honestly
feel like that's gonna happen and I feel
like that's what they're setting up with
a falcon Winter Soldier because like um
because this kid sees Falcon he's like
yo he's the new cap and like yo like my
dad was a Captain America so like I feel
like I need to be Captain America too
and um so he's gonna take that that
juice I know I like how you brought up
uh Emil Blonsky and like that whole
Incredible Hulk situation because like I
believe the reason why the leader is
even the villain of cat 4 is because of
the the super soldier program like the
reason why we have the Incredible Hulk
movie it's all because of that super
soldier serum yeah I really honestly
believe that um it's gonna be all about
the super soldier serum and like trying
to recreate that and mutant growth
hormone being like the sort of like uh
like a a trial version like they're
they're almost there but like it's like
all right we got a temporary version oh
let's just release it like we're almost
there so just release it out to the
market and let's make money off of it
because the power Brokers out here I'm
trying to give people Powers so I think
that she's gonna probably be involved as
well damn the power broker I didn't even
think about that for this yes oh my God
I don't know why I didn't even think
about that I just remembered her too
a smart Hulk look at you I didn't even
think about that you don't need a serum
no that that makes perfect sense I love
this series all right so in regards to
this theory of the mutant growth hormone
coming from the blood cells of She-Hulk
herself what do you guys think rogus
rogus all right what a rogus from
Whitney I've given it what do you think
Matt I also say a rogue baby let's go
let's go and what how do you think Jess
I am gonna give this
in August I'm gonna give this an August
because I think it's a very good idea
but I just want to see more Rogue about
it I want to see more rogus and it'll
also cure coven 19. okay wait a minute
now now it's a bogus no I'm joking I
want covered
um no I want you to be like delivering
like milk with it in and delivering it
to the kids to be drinking it or some
[ __ ] I want you to like be getting into
the lunch Supply I want you to be going
crazy with it but in the water supply
Cabin Fever it but I did like the idea
of it regardless I just want the
execution to be menacing menacing okay
oh I like that well you just said about
putting you in the water and [ __ ] I'm
kind of for them just go off that's
pretty dope because that feels like a
reaction to like how we don't have
Inhumans in the MCU right now like that
could be like how people get like it
feels very uh missed to me in humans
I would like that's really dangerous
serious I don't want that to happen I
don't want to accidentally go to drink a
little chocolate milk at lunch and
suddenly I
super powers that I didn't ask for the
thing is I'd rather have powers because
we saw how they were an avatar and I'm
not going to turn into an Iman and just
straight up be like I'm mad that I
didn't get any ability I'd be pissed I
always want to test it I want to see if
I can get something and if I don't get
anything then I'll turn into a villain
I'd want something super lame a super
lame power that I'd like make money as
long as I don't have immortality and as
long as I don't have just like a
physical one that gets me physically
like I turn into a frog looking creature
then I'd be hey what's wrong with frogs
huh what's wrong
he's in a suit he can take it off but if
I'm that girl from my hero Academia and
I just have a long tongue and I jump
from things she's kind of a weirdo you
know that's super power I want to get I
want to get Andrew gloverman's
superpower from big mouth that's right
baby every time I fart I want to turn
invisible that's pretty good at first I
was like that's right the kid that
kissed his cousin I was like trying so
hard to think of like his superpower
yeah that kid every there's a superhero
episode of Big Mouth there's a whole
episode that takes place in a
character's mind where all of them
randomly wake up with super powers and
everyone has really cool Powers except
for Andrew who farts when he turns
invisible I will take that that way no
one knows who did it
exactly then no one knows who dealt it
if they smell it exactly now if you turn
you can turn invisible until you fart so
I couldn't like go up and like you know
I don't go behind like say that
someone's giving a press conference and
like sneak it behind him and fart
because it's yeah no because it yeah
because then that would turn you back
visible oh [ __ ] you have to you have to
fart yourself visible and then unvisible
yeah so that's a high pressure yeah it's
like a two-fart situation imagine you're
like you're like about to do a job
interview you're nervous you fart and
then you just turn invisible it's like
no I got I get this job interview Mt
only you are farting during a job
interview
nervous toots
like hold on I gotta Force another one
hold on
next Jess has an interesting theory
about the weird wedding in Shield
episode 6 that she's gonna get into but
first be sure to check out our awesome
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com we currently have two
I put one finger up but two latest
Obsession shirts available right now
including our She-Hulk inspired Lady
Justice shirt along with our Ash and
ruin shirt inspired by the house of the
Dragon you'll also find merch available
for rings of power and Andor so much
awesome content means so much awesome
Merck support the channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch options
over at the rockstarsmerch.com but
Whitney has our ad for us today take it
away Whitney all right ladies and
gentlemen a new product has just hit the
market and you're gonna be so excited
about it because it is zebra perfume
have you ever wanted to walk into the
Savannah acting like you goddamn own the
place Spritz on a little zebra perfume
it's gonna feel good you're not a horse
you're not no matter what they tell you
you are not a horse you are special you
are unique and better than horses and
you deserve to smell like it baby
exactly is it made of zebra um it's made
from zebra pheromones so in the same way
that they have uh tried to inject
She-Hulk to take out you know the human
growth hormone and make more hulks we
take a sampling from all zebra uh sweat
that comes from their glands their
pheromones we bottle it we package it up
you are gonna hit that grassland like
you are the king that's what's gonna
happen to you you are so much more
special than horses and never forget
that zebra perfume listen I have my
plans to wear my zebra perfume during
the premiere of the Mufasa movie that
they just announced because uh just uh
you know just being the theme of the
Jungle you need to have um my good zebra
perfume and also to attract a good zebra
mate the future just because zebra mate
is hard to find
yes I'm attracted to zebras uh you heard
it here first and when you find that
mate you gotta take off zebra
I was interested in this product when
Whitney was pitching it and then as soon
as Mt started pitching on it I didn't
want to buy it anymore
it got instantly crazy I was gonna
invest and now I'm pulling out
completely but anyway this leads us to
our second topic for today which we
presented by the lovely Jessica Clemens
take it away Jess yes has nothing to do
with zebras or horses it has nothing to
do with animals except for except for
dogs because all men are dogs there I
said it yeah I play softball and I love
catching balls in the Outfield I totally
get it I love it
you are a labrador Matt thanks my theory
is uh spoilers for the new episode of
She-Hulk by the time this comes out you
will have seen the recent episode of
She-Hulk I hope the one with Daredevil
I'm tired and also I spend a lot of time
with mt today so I'm allowed to treat
him like this my theory about this
recent episode of She-Hulk episode six
the one without Daredevil is that the
whole wedding is a sham I think the
entire wedding is staged not only is the
wedding clearly it clearly is like no
offense to She-Hulk you can see that the
art Department definitely had like one
little set location and was like okay
we're gonna invite only 15 people
there's not gonna be a dinner there's
not gonna be any food the money that she
used to buy her drinks is the same five
dollar bill over and over and over again
so I think I do the breakdown so I have
to look very closely at these things so
I think not only is it like a small
get-together I just think it's all
staged by Intelligentsia and even if
it's not the Intelligentsia I think well
no it is the intelligence yeah because
afterwards we get that zoom out of the
satellite camera I assume it's a
satellite not a hidden one anywhere on
site but I think it's a satellite camera
of Josh and in her and I think it's all
staged that's why uh Lulu Patty was like
I don't want you in She-Hulk form I want
you in gen form and I think that's I
don't think it's just out of like this
is my day I think it's out of like I
need you to do this for me because
they're trying to get her blood from her
even if she's drunk I think they're just
trying to get her at her lowest point so
they can [ __ ] her up I definitely think
that Josh Josh is absolutely 100 he's
too hot and too cool
all the right things like it's
I get that as a TV show but I have made
and maybe it's just me I have never been
in altercation where a man has been that
upfront about their intentions and I
have also been like interested in that
man also it's been reciprocated and that
man has come up to me and been like
you're the gorgeous woman here and I was
hoping to run into someone as pretty as
you like no and you're eating nuts
and like and that's the thing is that he
went into it like pretending to be
insecure because that makes her let her
guard down because he's like he's just
like oh I'm so awkward be my friend and
then she feels bad because he's trying
and then she gives him the time of day
and it's like no he's clearly from
intelligentia honestly there's a lot of
red flags that being like the major one
of being like why are you faking this
why are you faking me yeah and Titania
being there right right Titania's
showing up like yeah there's no way and
like Chad being the DJ okay
suspicious that guy that guy I can see
him like he's gonna show up again uh an
incredible uh
he's coming back baby I think he's
actually the not a plant I think he's
like he's just here to have a good time
he's gonna be like you know in what if
you probably DJ'd that Thor party
I hope that actor gets more work but I
also think no offensive Chad if he was a
simple plant like it had to feel like it
was more like fluid and I feel like
getting Chet involved he was not paying
attention to anything around him but
playing like he's the whitest worst
music for a wedding totally
oh yeah did it bother anyone else that
they that he didn't play Ballroom Blitz
when Titania and She-Hulk were fighting
because I was like you're a DJ and you
don't know what a big song
The Electric the electrical electric but
that's not that's not as good as
Ballroom Blitz for a fight yeah it's
just because that's like a wedding song
right it's like I mean I I I've never
done that I've never heard that at a
wedding but I know that's like what it's
for right it's also like kind of an
older song that we did back in the early
2000s like even the Cupid Shuffle comes
after that somehow like it's there's
other wedding songs you could have chose
to do but they chose this one either way
that that's me being nitpicky about the
music I hated the music why don't you
leave a Yelp review for this wedding I
apologize sincerely to the enchantable
Hulk for myself for my disparaging words
it was probably the cheapest because
those songs are expensive to use even
within Disney's Library like they're
expensive so it's probably the cheapest
song you should have just played It's a
small world after all it would have been
uh
is so much more appropriate reusing
reusing the same five dollar bill was
the sign we have the seven dollars we
are running out of budget I felt bad
when I noticed it I was like how many
times are they just gonna turn the
camera a different angle because they
just like yeah upside down and I was
like it's still the same numbers still
the same numbers it's like we blew our
uh we blew our CG Budget on She-Hulk so
we have seven more dollars left we only
have seven dollars left East admissible
detail the production budget only that's
seven dollars again I love She-Hulk one
of my friends writes on it I'm obsessed
with it but I can point out a lot of the
technical flaws in this where it's the
five dollar bills the ADR is very off in
a lot of places and I'm not gonna get
into the visual effects because I don't
care about it get over it you guys and
to follow and the last thing to follow
my theory is the fact that I think which
I brought it up in our inside Marvel
that will come out a day tomorrow
yesterday uh when this comes out I that
it Josh is such a plant that I think
that he's a part of the Intelligentsia
in a way that they which is this is kind
of a stretch but I think men will go
this far when they're talking about on
the intelligentia website like She-Hulk
sucks I went on a date with her and she
didn't like me because I talked too much
she didn't like me because I was too
strong she didn't like me because I
didn't pull out a chair so they're
making this mock version of a man for
She-Hulk that is Josh who is a perfect
guy and it's just that he knows he's the
exact opposite of what Arthur Noah Derek
all those boys Todd all those boys were
yeah and it's and I'm like but the thing
is he still has that red flag like when
he said he's too easy he's using the
Barney Stinson playlist
we get it we get it Andy approached her
when she was like blasted drug oh yeah
come on yeah red flag come on Jessica do
you even think that her friend getting
married uh the oh the light system uh do
you think the that her friend getting
married like that was a plant too like
her her best friends or like her friend
from like fourth grade or whatever yes
two reasons a we never see we never see
her with Adam the husband uh two and the
post credits are in the courtroom
illustration she's making out with Chad
and so I'm like I'm like you can be as
open as you want but it's your wedding
day and you're not making out with your
husband in the photo booth you're only
making out with [ __ ] that's wild I think
I just think it's all a plant everything
was too easy It's too convenient yeah
Titania showing up totally for the
random date her being treated like crap
it's all a mind game they're trying to
break her down like mentally right like
this whole the whole show I mean hell do
you think even like when the moment she
put herself out as She-Hulk on the
dating app like all those guys that she
did did were they part of it too to like
break her down mentally yes
because after the first attack on on Jen
right after the first physical attack on
gen that didn't work so maybe this whole
season all of that's been planned the
intelligence is literally like Andrew
Tate and everybody
everybody every man on the show is like
I'm not for it but I don't I see where
they're coming from like because that's
how I feel about every date she went on
they could easily each be a part of that
website the Intelligentsia based off of
like one trait like Derek the wrestler
is like yeah is like um yeah She-Hulk is
weak I'm stronger than her I'm gonna
join this website and I'd be like what
it's just like her she's out there you
know it's like it's a it's sad to see I
want her to succeed I like I like her so
much I love her and I I think she's
great and I think she's great as Jen and
as she exactly she's so she is easily
I'm not and this is bold but she's my
like favorite character I think in the
MCU she's so fun I would go get a beer
with her I want to hang out with her
she would carry me home conscious 20
would be excessive 19. she would she
would carry me home like a little baby
and tuck me into bed after I got too
drunk with her it'd be great that's all
I want her and Wong I would want to hang
out like all the time and obviously
Madison's coming I mean she's if Wong's
there Madison is coming too the show has
to like you know improv Matt uh it it
can't it has to it can't be as grounded
as we want it to be like clearly I don't
I don't I oh God I don't even want to
say this a lot but like not every guy Mt
who does not act like those men you Matt
do not act like those men
not every dude yeah exactly most of them
are there's a lot of them but not all of
them not there's a lot of them I do not
put me on team man I'm still team woman
I'm still team woman too I'm also team
woman no there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
a lot of real bad real real bad people
out there dude yeah no I I really like
this theory of like all them being
plants because that wedding was so
awkward and so weird and it just felt
like it was this last minute planned
like all right here's a wedding here's a
bunch of people in a room dress up nice
I will say I've been to a couple
weddings that are like that we talked
about that on inside Marvel we were like
it's a very la like wedding yeah it is a
very early wedding yeah I'm kind of
exhausted on weddings right now y'all
I'm not gonna lie like the last two
years it feels like everyone I know it's
like very rushed I don't know Matt I'm
really sorry that I just got engaged and
I added to that congratulations
I like it when it's about the mayor
marriage but you can tell when they just
like it's not really about the marriage
it's like about either the family or
like you know yeah a little hate that
okay but you guys I just realized
Jonathan the dog was also a plant yes
Jonathan is actually a scroll John was
absolutely implant because he was
actually dead during the entire take
dude yeah that was
starring Jonathan that was weekend at
Jonathan's that dog's actually a robot
and that's how we got the footage yeah
oh my God that would be hilarious
Taxidermy robot dog it was at first
level you know what I mean
yeah don't mind us my dog's just
watching a date actually this is the
third dog in the MCU that's been injured
second dog that's basically dead uh
because we got Sparky One Division and
now we got him and then we got the
Hawkeye dog that's blind in one eye so
the hey MCU I see where you're going and
you need to stop stop hurting my dog we
need to stop I see you stay away from
Pugsley I like them in town
yeah yes let's talk about this Theory
what do you guys think about justice
theory about all of these people at the
wedding being a plant I think it's rogus
but what do you guys think double triple
quadruple a million quadruper million
rogus that's the most roguesses I think
that this is the hardest I've ever
rogused because I agree that intensely I
I'm I'm a rogus uh but I don't think
it's everyone I do think her friend is
actually getting married but they weasel
their way in to the party but I do think
it's rogus okay okay because weddings
are sloppy baby weddings are messy baby
they're sloppy I think I did pretty good
looks like I'm gonna go buy land now
with all these roguses
I'm gonna buy land and I'm gonna get my
name on a railroad to our railroad still
a big deal
yeah yeah get your name on a goddamn
cross-country railroad I think I'm gonna
do it I think I'm investing well right
now if I do that so I'm gonna go to this
you really are yeah I fully support he
just wants me to fail in life
I just believe in US
interactive uh like murder mystery
railroad
yeah murder on the Orient Express
foreign
have a railroad yes the next Rogue
Theory will be on a train uh
coincidentally it will yeah and patrons
get to buy uh uh stock everybody gets 10
yeah you get to buy stock in our train
like a Time the biggest donation to
Super Chat on break room will get to be
the conductor God damn that's how
capitalism works but now it is time for
our Rogue question you guys ready for
this one oh yeah all right because with
the news coming out this week that Keanu
Reeves the most beautiful man in the
world the nicest man on the planet will
be returning to play Constantine in a
sequel nearly 20 years after the first
film what long forgotten hero would you
like to see make a rogus return after a
long absence can the person be dead sure
yeah but it has to be another corpse it
can't be them
okay okay so it's like Doctor Strange
style basically okay okay so then my
pick is obviously Dalton from Roadhouse
uh that is a guy who could absolutely
come back do do Roadhouse two fix up
another bar maybe get into the MCU a
little bit you know that uh that bar
where uh Eddie Brock was hanging out at
the end of no way home he could start be
in a cooler there not a bouncer a cooler
where every Mantra and motto of every
staff member is be nice until it's time
to knock and that's what I want I did
I'm gonna go Whitney's route as well
with a dead person
um and I'm gonna do
reanimate my boy Gene Wilder and bring
back Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory with a living group
but he immediately Falls and his leg
like snaps off a little bit but he's
like
and then can you imagine that River Song
but with a dead man singing it yeah oh
100 it's directed by saying it's gonna
be great man and there's like Souls of
the dam in the chocolate River you know
like it's gonna be sick oh every time he
tries to save a kid he touches them with
his dead fingers I love Gina Wilder let
me get that first out there but I love
Gene Wilder too and I love Patrick
Swayze and I don't mean
I love those we just love them so much
we want them to come back we want to
come back even if they're zombies we'd
still love them we'd still love them
even if they were zombies there's a lot
of people I wouldn't want to come back
as a zombie I wouldn't kiss him but I'd
get them
that's fair what do you think Matt I
mean I don't think I want anyone back
because it's not oh for me sorry uh yeah
from I for me I I really want this is a
bit of a hack but I want the mystery man
back I want a new mystery man have Ben
Stiller still in it uh but it's written
by The Lonely Island uh and it's like
like current SNL cast members you know
and like I want a like it's just like 20
years later everyone's retired it's
never been Stiller who can't give up the
game no do do William H Macy let William
H Macy come yeah Casey can come uh yeah
if I want Mystery Men to come back I
think it's time I think the world's
ready for it with like today's like
sense of humor where is our Mystery Men
sequel let's go let's get this going man
oh yeah was on there yeah they're all oh
yeah and you got they're all right yours
is the only person who's alive so let's
start a petition yeah let's go
change.org bring Ben Stiller back is
mystery man yeah that would be so great
you know what I'm gonna have to give
that the Rogue question winner trophy of
the day Matt Mystery Men 2 has got time
oh yeah okay come on it's going so funny
it's going classic movie my goodness I'm
so surprised they never made like a
reboot of it or they tried I'm so
surprised they didn't right yeah
considering like the hyper superheroes
and all that stuff like well now they're
going to because Matt said so Matt just
spoken into existence and it's reboot
Time baby there you go Hollywood I will
take my paycheck I'll take that one's
for free yeah anyway that Jess are gonna
have so much land uh just kidding but
that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory I want to thank our amazing
guests Jessica Clemens Whitney van
leningham and Matt Acevedo for joining
us today follow them wherever they are
on the internet like on Twitter and
stuff you can support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you got thoughts on some of our
Rogue theories you can share them on our
Discord just to be over 18 and search
for the new Rockstar Discord server to
join the conversation you can follow me
at Mass retainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] you can follow the
new rockstars on all social platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our channel
here on YouTube we love you guys so much
thank you guys so much for spending time
with us we'll see you guys next time bye
bye the railroads I'm gonna build a
monorail
will make more money than the railroads
I can guarantee that
[Music]
thank you